good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is Prince gauche and I'm the
founder and CEO of boundary labs we're a
startup spun out of research done at
Case Western Reserve University today
I'm here to tell you how we're about to
redefine aerodynamics so the main
problem that we're trying to address is
the fact that wind energy still isn't
cost-effective enough to compete with
fossil fuels on a consumer level we
really see this as a function of two
major issues one wind turbines suffer
from aerodynamic drag and are thereby
less efficient and two at high wind
speeds turbines have to go through
expensive breaking cycles leading to
more wear and tear and higher operating
costs we saw this as an incredible
industry to enter really because of the
fact that there's about that there's
about 80 gigawatts of wind currently
installed in the u.s. today with over
50,000 plus operational turbines up and
running what we're really interested in
though is the wind turbine blade market
this is a market that's projected to
grow by about 43 percent by 2020 with
over a 10 percent annual growth in
installed capacity over the next five
years alone so what does our technology
actually do what we've developed is a
flexible adhesive plasma actuator that
regulates flow over wind turbine blades
that's a bit complex so let me explain
what it really does well we've design is
a thin flexible solid-state electrode
that can be applied right to the surface
of wind turbine blades as seen in this
picture on the left when activated the
electrodes ionize a thin layer of non
thermal plasma over the surface of the
blade and control the airflow with
electric fields this results in an
improvement of low wind speed
performance by about four percent and
also is able to protect the turbine at
high wind speeds by actually inducing
drag thereby slowing down the RPMs of
the turbine and leading to less braking
costs we currently have a provisional
patent application filed for our
technology and we're working with our
University's IP venture clinic to file
for a full patent application so what
does this really look like in this image
on the left you can
a typical test wind turbine blade that
we've developed in a winter in a wind
tunnel test facility what I really want
to point your attention to is that
turbulent dense air flowing on top of
that turbine on the left on top of the
turbine blade on the left now this is
that exact same turbine blade with our
technology on and activated with the use
of electric fields what we're able to do
is generate that thin layer of plasma
delay the boundary layer separation
point increase the overall lift of the
blade and thereby maximum power output
we see her Pat's a success as broken
down into five main stages phase one is
a conception of an idea the development
of a white paper raising a bit of
funding and also going through the NSF
Iker program where we conducted over 40
customer interviews with really key
executives and major wind energy
producers and OEMs speaking to the folks
who would make the executive decisions
on the business and technical side of
whether this technology was feasible or
not Stage two is where we're at right
now over the past few months and into
the summer we'll be conducting extensive
R&D testing focused on degradation and
optimization in partnership with NASA
Glenn Research Center in Cleveland phase
three is the first time our tech goes up
and on a turbine we're seeking to
partner with a wind energy producer to
have our actuators up and on blades in
lieu of stage four where we'll be able
to get our actuators on an entire wind
farm targeting turbines that were bought
under all the Power Purchase Agreements
and that are smaller in size about the
hundred to 150 kilowatt range so that
the turbine operators can maximize the
amount of energy output on those
turbines before they're 20 years
lifespan is over our eventual and final
goal doe is stage five what we want to
do is eventually partner up with an OEM
so that our technology can be integrated
straight into the wind turbine blade
design in terms of financials this is
really broken up into three major
segments phase one is where we're at
right now proof of concept and customer
discovery we're all money one and raised
through our and we're all money one and
raised goes straight towards R&D phase
two is where we'll be this summer and
into the next year of a wind operator
partnership where we'll be making a
certain we'll be making a profit based
off the individual revenue uptake on
each installed turbine
we'll be overall cash negative because
all that money is going to continue
straight into R&D and optimization of
our technology in lieu of stage 3 our
third final stage at this point will be
cash positive because all of our
individual in-house manufacturing and
R&D will be eased back as we transition
into an IP license of our technology
straight with a wind turbine om so
Siemens gamesa GE so on and so forth
the value proposition that we're putting
forward is really two-faced space one is
we're able to we're able to offer
enhance control over blade velocity and
phase two is we're able to reduce
aerodynamic drag over turbines with no
moving parts whatsoever this results in
two things decrease costs and increase
revenue the major factors in decrease
costs are lowered brake usage and
maintenance times and those were
increased revenue are widened cut in and
cut out speed ranges increase
operational time and maximization of
energy output
this is a typical wind turbine power
curve that any wind energy producers
used to seeing now this is that same
curve with our technology on and
activated by lowering the minimum
cutting speed and increasing the maximum
cut out speed for these turbines we're
able to maximize the amount of area
under the curve and juice out every
single kilowatt of energy that these
turbines can produce through extensive
industry analysis we've come to realize
that some of the major competitors in
the wind energy industry buy for even a
one percent improvement in aerodynamic
efficiency we're confident that the four
percent we'll be able to offer will be
strongly adopted by the market what I'm
really excited to tell you about though
is some of the societal impacts our
technology has if 100 percent of wind
turbines an American have can have our
actuators on them this will lead to an
equivalent of 16 coal power plants being
displaced off the grid five million plus
cars worth of emissions taken off the
road
which generates enough excess energy to
power the state of Illinois nine times
over some of our major competition on
the direct side comes from a small
start-up up in Connecticut focused on
using similar boundary layer
manipulation technology to control to
control airflow through the IP that
we've filed we've been able to not only
do that but also offer protection from
high wind speeds by actually inducing
drag rather than reducing it and slowing
down the RPMs that the
turbines have to go through on the in
direct competition slide a lot of that
comes from advancements from major OEMs
focused on pitch control improvements
lighter materials and mechanical
improvements the big thing here is that
while all of these advancements are
small and steady they're impossible
they're nearly impossible to be
integrated into the entire existing
turbine fleet that's up and functional
right now that's where our technology
comes in some of the really interesting
use cases for defense that I want to
quickly touch base about today are
really the traditional active flow
control over mid sized UAVs so the
Reaper over here on the left improving
aerodynamic efficiency to lower fuel
costs but then this case on the right
over here a couple of weeks ago we had a
chance to speak to a few Air Force
pilots at RPE
a Department of Energy conference we
were at and we found out from them that
when performing mid-air refueling
maneuvers a lot of the wake and wash of
the airflow coming off of the boom
system so that cylinder you see from the
tanker to the jet causes a lot of
unsteady turbulence for the fighter jet
pilot themselves we're seeking to apply
our actuators onto the boom to smoothen
and streamline that flow making it safer
for the pilots and making the overall
fueling system more efficient we think
that we can do so with the total budget
about up about $15,000 with the main
line-item rehear coming in through
Windtunnel rent time over at NASA Glenn
Research Center like I mentioned earlier
we're team comprised of undergraduate
master's and PhD students in mechanical
engineering aerospace engineering data
science material science and business
we're also advised by a phenomenal team
of business advisors strategic advisors
legal mentors and technical advisers
particularly dr. Mario Garcia saans our
technical adviser who's a world-renowned
expert in energy and control systems and
a current technical director at RPE the
US Department of Energy's Advanced
Research Projects Agency ladies and
gentlemen my name is Prince Ghosh and
I'm the founder and CEO of boundary labs
I have a vision that one day every
single wind turbine in America will have
our technology on it I'm hoping that
each and every one of you can join me on
that journey thank you so much
[Applause]
next thank you very much for that next
we have a team from Carnegie Mellon
ecotone
hello I'm a sasha Cohen at une Douce and
I'm Dylan Lu and we are ecotone
renewables so personally I've never
eaten an apple corer and I bet that many
of you haven't either but just because
we don't eat this court doesn't mean
that it shouldn't have value why should
we throw it away when we can turn it
into something else that would benefit
us currently 16% of families in the
United States are food insecure and yet
we're wasting 40% of our food supply why
are we paying to waste cause excess
amounts of traffic congestion and also
rely on unsuitable sources of energy if
we're putting all this time energy and
money into producing nutritious food for
the people of this country we see this
as an amazing opportunity to capitalize
by converting this energy on or near
sight until now the main solution has
been to set has been to ship away this
waste into centralized facilities like
landfills but the centralization has way
too many externalities and so we propose
a new solution the solution is called
the sea horse the sea horse takes
otherwise wasted time energy and money
and it puts it back into the food system
for every meal we can be saving
restaurants 25 cents and waste hauling
fees producing 100 kilojoules of energy
and also producing a quarter of a quart
of fertilizer this all fits neatly into
a 10 by 10 foot shipping container which
is just slightly larger than the average
dumpster this system can divert 12 tons
of food waste a year creating a $30,000
revenue stream of fertilizer and
continually producing energy sufficient
enough to cut nearly all electricity
costs for small business we are helping
other businesses in society by avoiding
high hauling costs avoiding odor and
externality risks and as well as capital
and time overruns we have a high return
on investments than other renewable
energy resources as we sell fertilizer
which is easily marketable and
beneficial to local communities we also
reduce energy costs and emissions which
in turn improves both individual and
communal energies
we are currently partnered with an
anaerobic digestion company in Seattle
called impact bioenergy our partnership
allows us to practice and license at no
cost because we're using their patented
gas cleaning separation and scrubbing
technology as well as their tank layout
and electrical design we're taking their
designs and we're scaling them down so
that they're more accessible to smaller
businesses so that these businesses can
improve their energy ecotone renewables
is working to improve our designs so
that we can work with permitting and
policy standards so that this design is
accessible in urban areas there is no
other system on the market that
capitalizes off of both energy and
fertilizer byproducts as you can see on
this chart the x-axis represents social
and economic benefits while the y-axis
represents degrees of locality the more
local the solution the less amount of
time and money we are spending on having
a negative impact on the environment the
higher the benefit the more we the
people are getting out of our waste
removal practices on the bottom left you
can see that we are paying to waste
these renewable resources and so we want
to deploy scale appropriate systems so
that we can receive as many benefits as
possible
currently organizations have been paying
fuel tipping and waste hauling fees and
we want to remove these fees and
externality costs we're allowing we are
allowing organizations to return their
investment within one and a half years
Germany is currently the only other
country in the world that does
commercial anaerobic digestion so we
took their market and applied those
ratios to the United States giving us a
thirty four billion dollar national
market we took that into our serviceable
available market which focuses on
restaurants apartment complexes college
dormitories and food distributors
because they all waste in between 10 and
15 tons of food a year they all have an
internal call to action it is also
completely possible for them to separate
their wastes because countries like
Sweden Norway and Portugal are already
doing this and we're allowing them to
receive additional revenue through
fertiliser and decrease their energy
costs the average restaurant can say
four and a half thousand dollars a month
on removing waste hauling fees alone we
have three revenue streams the first of
which is the sale of our seahorse system
in addition we offer the market users a
platform we have an operation
subscription which allows them sorry
about this we have an operation
subscription where we take control of
the operation of the system in exchange
for 9% of the revenue based on these
revenue streams we expect to sell 40
seahorses by year 5 and reduced
production costs by year 4 we are
receiving weekly interest from both
local and international companies and we
expect this interest to grow this is
because society is pressing for these
sustainable solutions the u.s. is aiming
on having 17% of its energy be renewably
sourced by 2023 states and numerous
European countries have already banned
organic scraps and landfills and to make
this solution even more accessible due
to its compact size we are avoiding many
of the costly permits which applied to
more larger scale industrial systems our
team is comprised of a diverse set of
skills with students from Carnegie
Mellon the University of Pittsburgh and
the University of Michigan in addition
to our team we have three advisors the
first of which dr. Deborah Stein has
worked for the white house is a
Technology Policy specialist and
currently works for the Scott Institute
for energy innovation dr. Leanne
Gilbertson at the Swanson School of
Engineering helps us establish local
connections while we work closely on our
designs with Jan Allen a civil engineer
from Impact bioenergy our partners
include impact bioenergy the local for
one - food rescue which connects us to
over 300 restaurants in Pittsburgh as
well as the national repair the world
which connects us to communal gardens
across the country we have currently
raised over $100,000 on our system
design and we have deployed Pittsburgh's
first portable aquaponics farm this will
also be our first seahorse site and
we're excited to see where a project can
go from there we are ecotone renewables
we are closing the food loop and we are
creating a 21st century food system
thank you
[Applause]
thank you lassen final presentation team
is for waste lists from the Penn State
University
okay
everyone poops and this is a serious
problem when it comes to energy and
water conservation in the u.s. water is
typically treated and then transported
to us homes a portion of this water goes
to outdoor activities and the rest of it
becomes waste water the average person
living in the US produces about 70
gallons of water per day and of this the
large the toilet is the largest
contributor so let's see how this scales
each person like I said flushes seven
has 70 gallons of wastewater per day and
of this twenty of 20 gallons goes down
the toilet so if someone has a 450
annual water bill per person fifty of
those dollars are going down the toilet
with a population of 327 million people
in the u.s. that 70 gallons becomes 2023
billion gallons of wastewater each day
and 6.1 billion gallons of twat of water
flush down the toilet
it takes water must be treated and then
transported before it returns back to
the home when this process takes a lot
of energy it takes ten billion kilowatt
hours of energy just for that toilet
water cycle in dollar in in terms of
dollars that's 1.2 billion dollars worth
of electricity toilet manufacturers and
government regulations have been making
efforts to reduce the toilets water
footprints but still we either need
copious amounts of water or high
pressure flushes so to reduce the
toilets water footprint while
maintaining a clean toilet surface we
need a slippery coating so to address
this issue we've produced what we call
the liquid entrenched porous surface
which we refer to as less as you can see
on the left toilet conventional toilet
surfaces are prone to residue build-up
foul odors and the accumulation of
disease-causing bacteria as they're not
regularly maintained but our coating
stands out from its pure hydrophobic
coating technologies and its ability to
repel solid waste in addition to liquid
waste any residue that does attach to
our surface can be washed away with 90
percent less water than I can
no toilet surface so this is how our
coating compares to a conventional
surface but you might be wondering how
does it compare to a state-of-the-art
hydrophobic coating so as we see here
our surface outperforms even the
state-of-the-art super hydrophobic
surfaces and slippery smooth surfaces
here in terms of its solid repellency so
our coating leaves less residue and that
means it requires less water to clean it
we further validated our technology
through a collaboration with Cranfield
University this group received funding
from the Gates Foundation for the
reinvent the toilet challenge and they
reached out to us with this particular
issue of fecal residue on the toilet
bowl so in their tests they drop human
waste onto a surface onto different
surfaces and they allow this surface to
slide and then they see how much residue
was left over and as you can see on all
of the other surfaces they tested all of
the way sticks but on our surface all of
that waste slides away but even in the
case that we had some residue left on
our surface it would still take up to
90% less water to clean our surface
compared to the state-of-the-art so for
households rental managers universities
large-scale institutions basically
anyone who's footing a water bill
toilet surface that can suit can consume
ninety percent less water would mean
money savings but at the national scale
it would also lead to large-scale energy
savings we've already filed a patent on
this coating and as you can see here
from this video IRA coating can already
be applied to toilets we are planning to
conduct further customer discovery in
conjunction with some technical
optimizations to see what coating method
our customers would prefer our current
plan is to first conduct a pilot test at
our home institution of Penn State
University and we've already started
making arrangements with our custodial
manager there if this is successful we
intend to reach out to other
universities leveraging the reach and
the leadership that this custodial
manager has with the Big Ten Network and
also setting janitorial standards
other institutions and once we've made
some initial sales in this in
institutions we'd like to extend our
reach into retail and eventually we want
to see our coding in every toilet in the
country when it comes to large scales if
you consider Penn State University we
have a student enrollment of over 46,000
students and that means that on one day
we're flushing almost one school day
we're flushing almost a million gallons
of water down the toilet in energy in
terms of energy alone that means we're
flushing away almost seventy thousand
dollars and we can save a lot of this
with our coding however based on
interviews over a hundred customers that
we've already conducted through our
experience in the National I Corps
program we do understand that we can add
significantly more value to institutions
by reducing the labor associated with
cleaning the toilets at the individual
individual level we can save homeowners
significant amounts of money per year
just on their water bills and nationally
these savings would extend to instead of
spending flushing trillions of dollars
down the toilet each year we could be
flushing significantly less from a
potential savings perspective if our
coding were applied to all the toilets
in the United States institutions and
workplaces would see savings potential
savings of seven and a half billion
dollars households would see 15 billion
dollars of savings and our plan is to
price our product based on these
possible savings allowing the end-user
to keep some of these savings and then
we would keep the rest as revenue to get
a little bit more specific in terms of
our financial goals
we intend to focus our first focus our
first year on developing a Minimum
Viable Product for institutions our
second our second year would be set
spent optimizing this MVP in developing
a commercial product for institutions
while also working on tweaking this
commercial product into an MVP for
households and retail in our in our
third year we hope to have reliable
institutional skills sales there are a
number of us
of non market drivers for this
particular technology at the
institutional level all the way up to
the national level for example at our
home institution of Penn State there are
a number a number of energy-saving
initiatives as well as committees
dedicated to making sure that the
university makes choices that promote
reduction and energy and also reduced
water consumption at the national level
there are also policies in place such as
the Energy Policy Act of 1992 which sets
a limit on how much toilets can flush
can send away per flush there are also
other programs that incentivize reducing
this flush volume even further from what
the policy prescribes our team is
composed of a number of PhD students all
of us have a material science background
we have a professor on our team from
mechanical engineering and our mentor
has had twenty plus years of startup
experience we've worked on a number of
projects together both in the lab and
outside such as in the iCore program so
far we've been developing our technology
since 2015 and we've also been
validating it through various
experiments and with this reinvent the
toilet challenge through camp our
collaborators at Cranfield University
and our next steps are - we have some
technical milestones which include
conducting this pilot test at Penn State
and we also have a number of business
milestones as well
currently we are participating in the
Ben Franklin tech stellarator program
where our goal is to surround ourselves
with experts and advisors with that can
fill in the gaps in our team and give us
additional experience and up and
expertise we'll also be looking into
different aspects of our supply chain
structure and also
regulations relevant to our product but
ultimately we want to revolutionize the
way that waste is managed with a coating
like ours toilets new one day be able to
keep themselves clean while reducing
their environmental impact thank you
[Applause]
let's thank our team for a great
presentation thank you so please give us
a few minutes to determine the results
of the judging good luck to everyone
very good excellent innovative ideas
thank you